my first experience of vewy as a black
child was negative actually the space
that I feel offend wash my face
why are you that color why are the palms
of your hands and the base of your face
why
the rest of you in school I was the only
black girl in my entire year
Wow I was the first of my family to be
born yeah so a lot of my friends are
seminars their parents came over for
what a better life and I almost thought
that we were institutionalized into the
Western Way of thinking we would talk
like so many years that you know why it
is beautiful
we've got all our aunts he's not like
using skin bleach because they want to
get lighter because we were taught that
being lighter was beautiful
but then now you're getting like white
girls Brian Dog Foundation and it's kind
of like where do we belong
[Music]
my first experience infinity was using a
really moosie foundation that came in
one of two shades were like all black
women it didn't fit any one shade and
I'm gonna be using like the tone that
was far too light for me and I just
looked hello dr i spent probably from 14
to 16 just that dislike ring of white
it's good bad around my face it looked
like I was a goth looking at the beauty
industry it was really confusing so it's
like I know what I want to be I can see
what I want to be but the industry isn't
it showing or I should look like we've
come a long way representation and
beauty but it wasn't something that I
saw after growing up 10 or 15 years ago
I would say I don't see myself they're
not yeah is this something that's real
or is it a trend yeah they're like head
back laughing and I was really obsessed
with the shape of her mouth when it was
open like being in the bathroom trying
to recreate that kind of like how as an
adult you know that none of that
messaging was anything to do with
talking to women like me I actually used
to skip past the Beauty pages and
magazines because there was never
anything that spoke to me
get your magazine and they have like the
free tiny self resound place this can't
use this free sample no I'm just going
to give it to my white friend if you
will can tighten boots or like a
department store there weren't any
shades you have to go so Mac you'd have
to go it's like a high-end luxury wanna
look up to this image but it's super
Eurocentric it's super whitewash and
it's like but you want to be this young
black girl who explores all these
different things who plays with makeup
who you get into this regime but there
is no access should always be fight
towel and a black one that haven't been
considered oh you know the drawing board
together
yes very you can always tell when you
haven't considered the fact that black
women have to tend to have two different
shaped lips yeah so then your sheer lip
sticks aren't gonna work for us we need
to see more skin like yours on the front
of magazine when I go to fire foundation
I want to see you in the ad not just
have the colors there it's a lot of big
brands they have the colors there but
those colors aren't represented in the
actual campaign which is
[Music]
there hasn't been as much room for
different styles of black beauty I think
when I first started feeling represented
interview industry was really probably
they lost yeah well there was so much
that needed to happen but it's like a
lot of those happened in quite a short
period of time
Rihanna did something really special
with Betty she almost a blueprint for
them to step up their game so now
there's a lot more ranges and colors
like it's not even just for the
dark-skinned as well as so everyone you
have beena Albina and just dip all types
of shades so not only are there more
shades but there are different
undertones we're not all red undertones
some of us are dark with a yellow
undertone or neutral undertone and I
think she definitely helped and since
venti basically everyone has extended
their colors like L'Oreal has got
thousands of colors now like everyone's
got loads more colors now brands know
that if they come out with a foundation
and it has like ten shades of beige
we're not having there's so many brands
nowadays that are using so many black
models so many like influential people
music people but in a way black women
still have to fight for their place to
get that certain role why does it just
have to be one black girl and then you
know that's the buster focus yeah why
can't they be 10 black girls
the PC industry has a lot of work to do
when it comes to like representing women
of color
we're so cool right now like that zach
has very the city of the Jews
there's all these cool Instagram pages
with dark-skinned girls on it but my
fear is in 10 years time when I've got
my kids and their boy we're not are they
going to see themselves almost this just
this cool thing that happen in 2018 2019
it's definitely a positive time but if
it's not just a time and it's kind of
illustrative of something slightly more
permanent